this [ __ ] bird they have these this
plant that it drops their seeds and then
the birds it was like catch on you know
it catch on the birds feathers then when
they fly they drop and they spread their
seed sure unless because they're sticky
like giant feathered bees keep going
kind of unless there's think of seeds
covered with honey the real stick I do
all the time well [ __ ] is this bird it's
some some of these birds land they're
like oh cool food they go down plot and
there's a bunch of seeds on the ground
well now you're covered in these honey
singh they can't fly I can't fly so it
show this bird-like with the [ __ ] man I
lose my friends with a [ __ ] man haha no
listen animal planet is there we could
spray him off maybe I'm getting there
now we're gonna film this for the next
48 hours as he passes away and cries out
to his friend [ __ ] implies if excuse
longer Oh guys a starvation no and
today's yeah the first of all there's no
way to ensure the soul thank God can you
pick the seeds office what better and
let the guy fly away we get it he's
going to die but at least 810 can't get
the way of nature melted I god I I was
wondering I was lucky to get these shots
they actually showed behind the scenes
because they're filming the [ __ ] in el
Komodo dragons oh yeah the dinosaurs
that is a dinosaur's the Beast lizard on
their mouths are droopy sure to see
haribol bacteria you should have seen it
they were so [ __ ] big show to
fighting forever was dope I'm like how
the [ __ ] did we get these shots like
maybe I'm like hitting cameras and
animals don't pay attention no no no
they hang out with these [ __ ] things
it showed one guy filming it lives like
trying to buy them but they have these
sticks what they like pushing back well
you know I God God oh and it takes them
to six to ten years to just film me you
know you don't want to get you out so
much patience you want to get bit by a
komodo dragon they are so oh they're
kind of every child yours does they're
dripping but you get a systemic
infection you'll get the worst kind of
strep staff / you know uncurable
bacteria but and its points as Rogan
says mother nature's a [ __ ] man you
watch out your God [ __ ] got hey Anna
please show me something pause f man
give me I mean you could have helped to
burn out with the seeds were you out
with that with the whole Connor Floyd
stuff I think it starting to get a
little old cuz
everywhere yeah but we're which is what
whatever happens with Connor dollars you
told because he is everywhere they
market the [ __ ] out of the guy and the
only star but he got some sama I'm not
hating on it I'm just saying it does get
old I mean when I was in Ireland the one
thing people complain about was Connor
which is weird and I'm talking about
actual Irish people what do you mean
they're like he's [ __ ] obnoxious and
I'm my Chloe because he's in the face 24
exactly i'm at bay see so much of them
and that that's it wasn't every [ __ ]
every person out there but there was a
handful people that said that but you
gotta see you I get it he's everywhere
but i think that UFC has to make that
fight they got a big bar what two
billion for billing I mean the moment I
think actually borrowed two of it right
they say they have two billion yeah yeah
there's nuts for Billy so they have to
get a return on that what's the fastest
way to get a return on that is to have
connor fight for her rug I mean you'll
make half a billion dollars as a company
luck that's insane so especially with
the marketing machine at yes he has
already and the marking machine that
Floyd is himself and that Connors has
become don't make so much money speaking
from truth and how did you up fight
don't uh-oh photo pick him apart yeah
you know Connor probably won't even
touch him you know disagree with that he
could I don't know he could but that's
the thing it's just like everyone kind
of assuming like we have no idea what to
such yeah the only realized today is
because I don't think it's me like your
traditional boxing match I think flowing
all right laughing Connor to me in this
weird stance has never seen easily
switch in South Paul to traditional
exact distance can be weird so that's
the only reason why I think he's going
to lay in certain stuff I don't think
Floyd I don't think toddler wins I think
he loses but by decision I could see
that you know Connors tough enough and
he hangs in there and that was a win for
example a serious human huge win for us
and for MMA is a sport and and i don't i
don't think that that you know I think
he's going to get [ __ ] destroyed yeah
but I think he'll just get cleanly
picked apart and it could be a decision
maybe he could get finished you never
know I thought it was a bigger guy like
if it was like day and so and if it was
like a Canelo Alvarez who's in his prime
his like a Mac [ __ ] trouble will walk
you down and crush you g'nite Eagle of
kin and that then he doesn't get out of
the first round yeah but Floyd he is
pounced island greatest of all time
great
defense we the counter fighter any not
amount of this showman he's going to
make us fight maybe he's not going to
have people paid a hundred dollars paper
you which I bet it is Hunter out baby
and then just yeah Merc this dude in one
round which you know he what will
probably have a big storm yeah he'll let
Conner swing shots at him from [ __ ]
fly it for 12 rounds just like he'll
just sit back and slip out of the way
and catch him slip out of the way catch
him slip out of the way catch him he
might get hit with one or two but I
think I mean you ready for this can you
imagine Connor not come on that sofa if
you're sick of them now oh god I'll be
so [ __ ] hilarious I'm going to face
that too I'm just on a smaller area it's
about greatest of all time and just ruin
my career just for the [ __ ] of it for a
while there is running strip bars all
over the country you would like flip
strip bar so you get called in like
we're not making the money you come in
and flip them he dado you gotta go fatty
guy go fatty got go fatty no ray shift
left now do not nothing social I we
ditched it and they're like nah I'm like
white grapes brilliant it's going to be
a little bit weird give me a little mean
this town is weird but every brother
can't like you gotta lose 10 pounds
sweetheart like we're doing this is this
i'm being these girls in revenue here
you don't get shitty customer service
black strippers i'm just going to say it
on the podcast they have no clue a
[ __ ] customer service hey baby I'm
just go all you got no money i'm gonna
yell at you and they [ __ ] they asked
you to go outside of fight I don't under
day walk off I've only said that haha
he's under if you hit the nail head I've
always said that it was have a real
issue oh my god that's so funny cuz cuz
they're just more upfront about why
they're there now my kid where you got
there romanticize me you get a lab it's
not Jesus citrullus me man let me think
there's a chance that reacts your job
man yeah sitting here I got money I got
stone cold cast my pocket yeah let's do
it girls will a free go suck a fight is
not invite oh you got probably got
problem you got a problem oh hell are
you taking me down a little bit a little
bit i hear extensions are obsessed